I'm working on the biggest project of my
entire life look at this picture this is
me when I left the United States for the
first time yeah I know it's super low
res digital cameras were awkwardly bad
in 2005 this first trip abroad for me
was to Mexico I was 17 years old and I
was really into parkour for some reason
a year later I saved up all I could and
I left again on another choice Paris
London Wales on this trip
while I was atop a castle ruin in Wales
is actually at this very moment right
here making this awkward teenager face
something clicked in my brain
hold on this is a my journal from 2007
[Music]
everything is so different my eyes feel
open really man that's like very cliche
world and then I ended up drawing what
looks like a poorly drawn caveman
painting that represents what I was
feeling
I wasn't sure who I was or what I
believed or what I was gonna be doing in
five years or what I wanted to be when I
grew up but in that moment this moment
here making this awkward
grin on the top of a castle ruined in
Wales by myself
I felt sure of one thing which you can
see in my little drawing I was positive
that my future would include me getting
on airplanes and exploring this planet
and that's what happened
[Music]
I got married and suddenly I had a
travel companion and then I had kids and
suddenly I had two or three travel
companions
okay so why am I telling you all of this
the stories and kind of this background
well because it has a lot to do with
what I do today and my career and this
big giant thing I want to tell you about
I've made a career out of going to
places and trying to understand them and
trying to communicate that story of that
place to a lot of people and one of my
major goals is to help people feel
empowered to travel for themselves and
to go to a place and feel more informed
and more connected with the place so
today I'm announcing that we are
launching a company it's the biggest
thing I've ever done and it's called
bright trips
[Music]
right trip is a platform a video based
platform where you can take travel
courses don't know what a travel course
is that's because they didn't exist
and then we invented them and now they
do think of bright trip courses as like
explainer videos with animation and tons
of video and explanation but that are
geared towards helping you prepare for
your next trip so if you're going to say
Tokyo you might enroll in a course that
teaches you about ramen its history what
makes a good bowl of ramen and how to
actually eat ramen when you're in Tokyo
that's a real example there's actually a
course on that in a bright trip course
you get a healthy dose of history and
context surrounding a place but then you
also get practical tips on how to take
on a city or how to roadtrip through a
certain place or how to order high-end
sushi these are all examples from one of
our pilot courses about Tokyo which is
hours of content that we have poured our
efforts into to make it the most
enlightening and empowering course
possible the goal of every course is to
give you a rich visual learning
experience so that these concepts about
a place will really sink in and we use a
lot of beautiful footage but we also use
animation to do this bright trip courses
aren't just about places like Tokyo
they're also about concepts and
techniques like how to travel with kids
or how to document your trip this is all
video based learning that you can take
at your own pace whenever you want after
you buy the course with every course you
also get a PDF guide that's kind of like
a summary or a cheat sheet of what we
cover in the course and for location
courses you also get a map that tells
you everywhere we went so that you can
follow along and choose to replicate our
itinerary if you want to but these
courses are not to tell you to do a
certain itinerary to go to a certain
place it's to empower you with knowledge
about a place so that when you get there
you can spend time experiencing it and
not just learning how to get around
we're also developing a course series
about advanced travel filmmaking the
professional thing that we do for our
careers going around and telling stories
in different countries we've started
with camera fundamentals which is how to
understand a camera which you can check
out in the catalog but eventually this
will be several courses that
to every aspect of travel filmmaking we
basically take everything we know about
this industry and about this career and
try to put it into these courses
[Music]
[Applause]
so this launches today it's launched
it's live bride trip calm go check out
the catalogue and see if any of these
courses are helpful to you as you think
about your next trip and these are just
our first courses it's a lot of content
but we want this to be a big catalog
full of tons of different courses I've
always operated with feedback from you
all and that has informed my work
forever and this is no different so tell
me what kind of course you want maybe
it's a place maybe it's a technique what
kind of course do you want in travel so
that's it I'm kind of nervous
this is kind of the biggest thing I've
ever done in terms of launching
something huge nan I'm about to actually
get on a flight to Portland to go see my
family so I hope you like right trip
[Music]
[Applause]